so if you're using a substitution method
you have to decide which variable you're
going to solve for you either want to
solve for this X this Y this X or this Y
I'm going to solve for this Y because
you can see there's just one y it'll
avoid having some fractions to deal with
it'll make it solving the problem a lot
easier so let's go ahead and solve for
this Y so if we do that we get negative
y equals negative 4x plus 7 multiplied
everything by negative 1 that gives us y
equals 4x minus 7 ok now we know what y
equals and that came from the second
equation here we're going to put what y
equals in place of Y into our first
equation on top there so that's going to
give us 2x plus 3 times now instead of Y
we're going to put what y equals 4x
minus 7 equals 7 okay now we just have
to solve this equation so this is going
to be 12 X minus 21 we're just doing the
distributive property combine like terms
we have 14 X minus 21 equals 7 so that's
going to be 28 which means that x equals
2 okay now if we put 2 we can put it
back in for this X here or this X here
this is going to be the easiest because
we already have Y by itself so if we put
2 in for X we get 8 minus 7 which is 1
and so we can see that our point of
intersection of these two lines is going
to be at 2 comma 1 now if you want to
double check your work you can always go
ahead and put 2 and 1 here make sure it
equals 7 2 & 1 here again make sure it
equals 7 and then you know that that's
the common point of intersection